Hello Freak bitches.
Oh d is this him again?
Again,
I wonder what year this was kind of just
trying to remember trying to number one,
the UFC brought back to 155 pound title
cause for a long time one 17 was the
lightest weight you could fly. You got
to give this to credit for his entrance.
Is it a lot of this? He obviously
does a lot of work, Huh?
Man Miller had a great one once he had
like a bunch of dancers behind him and
shit. He had a whole
choreographed entrance when he
fought in pride. I like that.
I mean he always had ridiculous entrances.
I don't know what was that?
What his ski mask he was, what
was that? Anybody stealing money.
Anybody who ever questions whether
or not may him was a good fighter.
Cause you know, may have had some hard
times and getting a little nutty lately.
But if you go back to why and mayhem
fought saccharide no, not soccer.
I soccer in pride dude.
He smashed Sakharova smashed and went
right through them and submitted them.
Really? Ooh. Yeah, pull it up
Jamie. See if you can find it.
It's already lost some
disqualification, ma'am. Yeah.
In the UFC and pride. Did he lose
one by disqualification? Boy,
I don't remember that. Did he? I Dunno.
I didn't see it. It was like on his,
this is his dream and just, Oh, there's
this was dream. This wasn't pride.
Wow. That's great. School
girl outfits. Come on.
How do you not love this?
Awesome.
No ma'ams had some tough times, but he's
always been cool to me. I liked that guy.
I love him. I see him. He comes out to my
shows when I do Irvine. He's a good man.
He's a great guy. I mean, he's got some
problems and you know, he was always,
he was always a extraordinarily
nutty dude. You know?
He did the MTV show for awhile,
by the way.
I ended up binge watching that
one day and watching dudes.
Fuck all you guys who don't know how to
fight. Yeah, it's amazing. You know what?
I remember one time when we were in
Australia for the fights years ago,
a rampage was there and I guess
those two are good friends.
So I was going from like different areas
in like this mini group with rampage
and every time somebody
wanted a picture with him,
they put their arm around is like,
you know,
like around their shoulder and
anytime he would throw their arm off,
get your fucking arm off.
And they were like, okay.
Then they'd be like scared for
their picture. Like Huh, like that.
So we're going like,
that was ramping up,
ramping up by the way.
I look,
people pinch my nipples and pictures
with me and pages and pleasure.
So I'm sitting like,
so I witnessed that that like
10 times. And then we moved to like some
bar somewhere. And you know, there's like,
I dunno if he's like roped
off people over here.
There's a lot of people in the place,
but it's like a small group like this
and brand pages here and may him comes up
and I don't know that they know each,
I don't know the relationship.
And he immediately grabs him by the
throat because like, I'm gonna kill you.
But the for the,
for a split second,
I saw like all this just split,
like violence come into random.
I was like, he was about to fucking murder
someone and then I saw it disappeared.
He saw him. He was like, you
crazy guys, white boy. But
like for for a quick second,
he turned like just to break them in half.
And I was like,
it was more terrifying than any fight
I'd seen. Rampage is a beast. Yeah.
That cinder block on his shoulders.
That head is oh, crack too. Yeah.
It's so hard.
Rampage had some epic fights in pride too.
Before you ever even came to the UFC.
He has the all time greatest
slam knockout over all time.
Greatest and the triangle.
Yeah. Oh, in a triangle.
Smashes him down to the ground and
what the fuck was the guy's name?
But he fought very good, uh, rampage and
a triangle rollout. Ricardo Romo stood up.
He, I'm going to fuck the guy
still had his legs around him.
He just picked him up. And then,
yeah, this is like, this is,
the dude went for the triangle,
but he was elevated and like watch,
go find the video.
In the video,
he went for the triangle
and rampage elevated like he
lifted him up and the dude
held onto the triangle, which
you just can't do. You got to,
you got to let it go at this point.
See when he's up like that,
you got to let go of the chart.
Oh my God.
Slam chaos is the greatest slam Kao ever
in the history of sport and he had them
around. Let's look at this. It's
like a pillow Glam to Daniel's.
Him with his head too. It looks like he
headbutted his face. Yup. He did that.
He actually got his eyebrow cut.
I mean this dude was just dead on the
way down. Watch, look, go right there,
right? Well, yeah.
I mean he just got fucking k. Oh,
did, did, did, did, did, did. It did.
This is the worst slam I've
ever seen in my life at all.
My years of watching fights.
God, yeah. I've never seen it.
Never seen anything more brutal, man.
I would love to see them do that.
The bird by bird. I'm just to
see it. Just to say it. Yeah.
But I can't take that kind of impact, man.
No, no. Around, it was never the same.
No more tickets, man. Growing
up. It's never the same after.
Never a runner. Was it like a
serious contender before that? Fine.
Kate sent me once in the, uh, in
that, in that gym that was downtown.
They had a little of one of that to show
companies the tap. I'll blaze. Nope,
the one, the Anderson's manager.
Oh, Yay. A black house. Yeah.
Yeah. And He, I was like,
I'm going to slam.
Looks like it was going to a light
one that was out for a long time.
You were not knocked out. I mean, like,
I couldn't like move. Right. Oh really?
He picked you up. He just left. He's
like, that's just a light. Like, yeah,
you got to learn how to fall before you do
that. I liked to him not to. Yeah, it's,
you got to kind of, as you go
back, you kind of like relaxing,
kind of slap the mat to dissipate
some of the energy for the real back.
Ever watch judo guys the role and as a
role rolling back, they slap the mat.
It's like a big, as loud
as shit. Yeah. Yeah.
It literally helps relieve some of the
energy of you hitting the ground is also
like relaxing,
knowing how to roll.
Okay.